-You look gorgeous.
It's always great
to see you, bud.
-So nice to see you.
It hasn't been that long.
-It hasn't been that long.
We saw each other
at a big night out,
opening night, Broadway,
"Sweeney Todd."
We saw each other.
I sat kind of across from you.
-I'd like to thank you
for your laughter.
-Thank you.
-You were really vocal and I --
-Was I laughing too hard?
-No, there's no such thing
as laughing too hard in a --
-You could hear me laughing?
-Oh, yeah,
we identified your laugh.
[ Laughter ]
But it's a comedy.
-Yeah, it is.
-Yeah. And, when you laugh,
you encourage other people
around you to laugh
because, if you think it's
funny, then it must be funny,
so, I just want
to say thank you.
-But now I'm a little
self-conscious because was I --
-No, keep giving it.
It's really nice.
-Now I'm thinking I don't know
what laugh I gave.
[ Laughter ]
Your husband, Thomas Kail,
amazing director, amazing guy.
What a show, by the way,
"Sweeney Todd."
-Yeah, it's really magnificent.
-Everybody -- Josh Groban,
Annaleigh Ashford.
Unbelievable.
Gaten Matarazzo
[ Cheering ]
from "Stranger" -- Yeah.
[ Applause ]
You got to see this play.
-It's amazing, yeah.
-Do you get nervous
if it's your husband's play?
I mean, he's directing.
-I was more nervous for him
than I ever have been for myself
at any opening
-Really? You're like...
-that I've ever --
No, absolutely.
-..."You guys better laugh
at this scene. It's funny."
-No, That's why, when I knew
it was you laughing,
I was like, "I love him.
-Yeah!
-I love him." [ Laughs ]
-Yeah, support him.
Yeah, because
I could imagine that.
But then he got up at the end
and also had to do a big speech
and I was like, "Oh, now."
You think you work hard enough.
-Even more nervous.
But he was great.
He was funny.
He's very intelligent.
I was like -- But I was --
I looked over at you
for a little bit
because I wanted
to see how you were.
You were watching him.
You were like,
"Yep, that's right, say that.
Alright."
[ Laughter ]
"Just like we rehearsed."
-"Good job, honey." Exactly.
"Just like we rehearsed at home.
Good job, honey.
Take it home."
But are you used to Broadway,
now that you got --
you were Tony-nominated?
Did you --
You did -- Was it "Cabaret"?
I think I saw you.
-"Cabaret"
and I did "Blackbird"...
-"Blackbird" -- phenomenal.
-...and, yeah, yeah, yeah.
-Did you grow up being
a Broadway kid
or did you want to do theater?
-You know, I started --
the first thing that I ever did
was theater,
so it really is
kind of my first love.
And even singing and dancing,
it was the first thing I did.
I was like a chorus kid
in, you know,
every production of every
children's theater thing.
-No way.
-Yeah, it makes me feel like
a kid again when I'm onstage.
It just makes me feel
there's a kind of like freedom
and expansiveness to it that you
really can't get anywhere else.
-No, there's nothing
like it, too.
And also to see a Broadway show,
too, I can't help it.
No matter --
-It's so exciting, isn't it?
-It's so exciting.
They work so hard.
I could never do anything like
that at all,
what you guys do, what they do.
But at the end, I'm always like,
when the standing ovation,
I get so misty
and so emotional,
like they're my kids.
[ Laughter ]
-Well, because --
-I'm like, "Yes!
You did a great job up there!"
Like they didn't care about me.
-It really is so brave, though.
Anything can happen. Like so
many things have to go right
to have a perfect show
and so you think like
you just think
about like the vulnerability
and the heart
of these performers
and it's really on display
in "Sweeney Todd."
It's just like it's so fun.
It's like a rock concert
for grown-ups.
-It is.
-It's moving. It's emotional.
And it's just incredible to see
people assembled in this way
and it's such
a big production, too.
It's a 26-piece orchestra
and this enormous cast
and, you know,
and people are finally
like brought back together
and the energy in the room
is just, you know.
-Yeah. It was wild.
It was so much fun.
But I was going to say also,
you can sing and dance.
Was it "Greatest Showman"
that I was watching?
You were unbelievable
in that as well.
-Thanks.
-Would you ever do another one
of those?
That's a giant.
It was a massive hit
in my house, at least.
-Oh, in my house, too.
-[Both] Yeah.
-I think the world loved it,
yeah.
-Most [indistinct].
-Most, yeah, yeah.
-Yeah, I would absolutely.
Again, like singing and dancing,
you're just sort of so tapped
into joy
and you can't really --
you can't -- you can't be --
you can't regret anything while
you're singing and dancing.
You can't really like go
backwards in time, you know?
-No, you're doing it
-Because you're so caught up
in what you're doing and the
thing is moving so quickly,
so, you you don't really
have time to be like,
"Was that a good way
to say the line?"
-Yeah.
When you're onstage,
are you thinking
about anything else
or are you just going,
"I'm doing my thing"?
-It's kind of an amazing --
it's an amazing way to --
It's an amazing kind
of concentration to find.
Because, you know,
because you can't stop it.
It's unstoppable,
unlike [indistinct].
"Oh, hang on, hang on.
I'm sorry. I'm sorry.
-"Let me try it again."
-Hang on. Let me try it again."
-"Can we start with the first
note? Thank you," yeah.
-It's like a train
that you can't get off of
and so it's really exhilarating
because, you know like,
even if you feel like you
missed a moment
or you slipped something up,
you don't have a choice
but to keep going
and so it's actually like
it's very enlivening.
-Congrats on your fifth
Oscar nomination, by the way.
-Thank you.
-Ooh.
[ Cheering and applause ]
[Indistinct]
-Well done.
-Thank you.
-Come on. You're doing it.
You're doing it pretty great.
-Thank you.
-Imagine that you're doing --
This is your fifth Oscar
nomination and you're acting --
Steven Spielberg
is directing you
and you're playing a character
based on his mom.
-I know.
-Talk about pressure.
[ Laughter ]
I mean, forget about singing
and dancing.
This is like, "Did I do it
right, Steven? Is this what --"
I mean, it's his mom.
-Well, he can tell you.
-Yeah.
-He's the world's
leading authority, so.
-On his mom, yeah.
-Yeah.
-So, if he's happy,
then you can like -- you can --
-How did that call --
Did you get the call
from Steven Spielberg?
Like, "Hey --"
-I don't know why he wanted
to talk to me.
I could not have imagined
that he wanted me
to act in a movie.
I thought he wanted to like
know where to eat
in Brooklyn or something.
-[ Laughs ]
You can help him with that,
too, yeah.
-It's still like halfway
into the Zoom
when we got on this thing,
I still just didn't know
what I was doing there
or what he could possibly
have wanted to Zoom with me for
and then it sort of like
went off like a...
bing!
in my head and I had to sort of
just stop and ask him like,
"Just so we're super like --
are you --
you want me to be your mom?
[ Laughter ]
And you loved her?"
Yes, okay, great.
-Yeah, "I just want
to make sure we're clear,
that we're both having
the same conversation," yeah.
"You want me to be your mom?"
-"Because I think you just
asked me to be your mom
[ Laughter ]
and that would be just
too crazy."
-It was phenomenal, the movie,
the whole story,
it was just fascinating.
Everyone did a great job
with this.
But I wanted to ask you --
if you can even zoom in --
what's it working like
with that monkey?
[ Laughter ]
I thought that was --
I would always want --
I really want to act
with a monkey.
-Have you ever worked
with a monkey?
-I wish. I would love to work
with a monkey.
-You should have her
on the show.
-Yeah, I'll book the monkey
tomorrow, yeah, let's go.
[ Laughter ]
-You should book the monkey
as like a recurring --
-What's the monkey's name?
They always have fun names.
-Crystal.
-Crystal the Monkey.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah.
-Fantastic.
And Crystal get --
Is it he or she?
-She.
-She. Does she get her own
dressing room, Crystal?
-She has like her own --
You never even see --
-World.
-Yeah. She has her own world.
You never see --
-Like does she come
in a different outfit
and then get changed
for the movie?
[ Laughter ]
-Well, she does wear a diaper.
-She does?!
-Yeah.
Come on.
That's so cute. Come on.
[ Laughter ]
I would love it
if the monkey showed up
like dressed a little detective
or something.
[ Laughter ]
-Well, she has an incredible
wardrobe. You should --
-She does?
-You should check
her out.
-I do want to have her come on.
-She has red carpet looks also.
-She has read
red carpet looks, too?
-Aww!
-Did you see Crystal in outfits?
-Oh, yeah. She's --
I'm not kidding.
You really should have
the monkey on the show.
[ Laughter ]
She can learn anything.
There's like nothing
that she has been --
There's nothing
that she's been asked to do
that she's been unable to do.
Like for this movie,
she learned how to
dismantle a chandelier
and throw lightbulbs.
[ Laughter and awws ]
-And that wasn't even
on her résumé.
[ Laughter ]
-The only thing that's hard
about working with a monkey is
like you can really
get upstaged.
[ Laughter ]
-Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah.
You go, "Oh, please. You're
chewing the scenery here."
-"Outta here, outta here," yeah.
-"Give me my moment."
-You don't want to do a dramatic
scene with a monkey.
-"I'm going for an Oscar here."
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah, yeah.
-This is her sixth nomination
for an Oscar for Crystal.
She's so lucky.
[ Laughter ]
But I think like I would be
a little afraid to like --
I feel like monkeys can like
feel your emotions or something,
so, if I got nervous,
I would make her nervous.
and then maybe -- would she
attack me or something?
[ Laughter ]
-No. No. But they do --
The monkey -- Her trainer said
that she does --
she likes to know -- she knows
instinctively who's in charge.
-Oh.
-And she befriends them.
[ Laughter ]
-Wow! She can feel it.
-So, she knew which one was
Steven Spielberg, yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-She's like --
Yeah, we got that take, right,
Steven? Alright.
[ New York accent,
smoker's voice ]
Thank you. Perfect.
[ Laughter ]
I appreciate it. Thanks a lot.
Ready for Take 2?
I usually don't do two takes.
Alright, here we go.
Let's talk about your new movie,
"Showing Up."
Congrats. You're getting
great reviews on this.
It's a comedy.
How do we set up this film?
-So, this is the fourth movie
that I've made
with my friend Kelly Reichardt.
-Yeah, you guys are
great together.
-Yeah, we've been working
together for 15 years.
The first movie that we made,
"Wendy and Lucy,"
was a crew of 13
and so this, for us,
is a much bigger movie.
-Wow! Thirteen people
on the whole set?
-Yeah, 13 people
on the whole set made a movie.
-Isn't that great, though,
to do that?
-That that's possible, yeah.
-That's possible
to make a movie.
"We're making a movie!"
-Yeah, it really is.
So, I think like that's always
the core of the work that we do.
You know, we've sort of --
we've trusted each other.
We've respected each other
for such a long time
and this movie --
actually, Judd Hirsch,
Hong Chau, and myself --
I know, I know. So, she's --
You know, three recent
Oscar nominees in this movie.
-That's right.
"The Whale" and --
Judd Hirsch -- "Fabelmans."
-Yeah.
-Oh, my gosh! Can we set up --
What is the film about?
-So, it's really about --
it's about being an artist
and it's about everything
that has to happen
before you can just sit down
at your table and make work.
And are they things
that we do to ourselves
or is it really
just circumstances
that are beyond our control?
And actually, are they part
of the creative process?
It's about how life gets
in the way
or maybe is a part
of art making.
-Mm! [ Claps ] There we go.
I want to show a clip.
Here's Michelle Williams
in "Showing up."
Take a look at this.
-Would you give this
to your brother
when you see him again?
For five years,
he lived in that jacket.
I mean, it was mine, but he
took possession. [ Laughs ]
He might like it again.
-Yeah, I remember this.
-Yeah.
-Have you talked to Sean?
-Yeah, I talk to him
all the time.
Come on, let's go.
-When's the last time
you talked to him?
-He bought a delicious stuffing
for Thanksgiving.
It was ravishing.
Let's go.
-Dad.
Dad, that was six months ago.
-Well, he was great
six months ago
and his stuffing was superb.
[ Cheering and applause ]
-Michelle Williams, everybody.
"Showing Up" is
in theaters Friday.
We'll be right back
with John Stamos.
Stick around, everybody.